hello and welcome to this video from
Yano 2017
so those declined bankers 92 here I
don't remember
I know it except now I do remember
actually this is a this is okay you can
also go here now let's play the simple
[Music]
it looks quite good m4y put the knight
on d5 is extremely strong
93 was maybe an option even one move
earlier don't know really can also just
put more pressure on the e5 pawn lots
looks good him how does he cover it it
doesn't
well okay little mate threatened
okay and now here I still 95 and it's
just strengthen the position a little
bit so
yeah this is just too attractive how to
not play it even though I'm not sure how
much it's really net 795 still possible
we have a g6 I mean to kill in chat much
ng - where's or under pressure
moving into this fork distance looks
really really strange but okay I don't
see a tactic
you
I don't see a convincing tactic here
submit as it looks look t fires kind of
hands here trying to bring the look over
I made this is actually good it looks
weird
somehow bit of a show-off move like you
cannot take haha I mean this is this
might be might be really dangerous so
let's try it threatening now to take on
g2 and take on h2 there's some some
things going on here okay
[Music]
you
cannot move the night now as made and
looks 25 look f3 photograph - made as
well it looks dangerous very dangerous
and I can just take it on on stem 1 okay
for is that too fancy looks good
[Music]
threatening work g1 with made again
check I don't that that's almost
impossible to defend in a game plate
behind can you look this is an important
tradition type in the bank oh this one
it's something that you might not at
first recognized as being okay for black
because that isolated pawn it looks a
bit strange but the thing is black gets
very easy development and if I call this
really is an issue black has a black has
no problems with the pawn on c5 already
I can just put pressure on the pawn if
he was was not really addressing this
and yeah I'm just a pawn up for for
nothing yeah I'm not sure about all this
I hope d5 is action strong smooth that's
great
yeah I didn't know it this is always
looks a little bit like sure I cannot
take the cause of 92 but it is really it
seems to be effective yeah to bring the
look over for the attack okay here we
should takes okay that's much easier of
course yeah I can just take and do this
that's a much much easier way to win
okay but the way it was are also quite
attractive g5 over here didn't see this
but this is also good yeah if he takes
here I am look f3 is actually to capture
to take the Queen what I was seeing is
this one which also wins because this is
made technique at the K Queen c5 is
ridiculous therefore you can take here
this is not this is still an ending
somehow
[Music]
they are playing for mate it's a
stronger and I worked you one egg now
though he overlooked it but I don't see
how black is going to how wide is going
to defend this thing
rookie 2 D 1 D 2 D 1 and then my G 1 Wow
and why this falling apart
yeah it was nice ok guys thanks for
watching